[Music]
on this tuesday night the millennium
scoop class action lawsuit the battle to
compensate off-reserve indigenous
children ripped away from their families
every single day i had to be prepared
for the worst the decades of harm and
heartache american election workers on
the record about threats do you know how
it feels to have the president of the
united states to target you mounting
evidence of donald trump's pressure
campaign to stay in power federal money
for mental health missing in action
mental health should be a priority where
are the billions the trudeau liberals
promised
and the art of a tribute google honors
an indigenous man dubbed the picasso of
the north
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
[Music]
indigenous heritage and traditions were
on full display across the country as
canadians mark national indigenous
people's day but at a time meant to
recognize and honor first nations inuit
and metis cultures members of the
community are wrapping up for another
legal battle against the federal
government
good evening and thanks for joining us
the federal court of canada has
certified a class action lawsuit against
ottawa on behalf of indigenous children
taken from their families during the
so-called millennium scoop they want to
see a shift in the law to stop what they
call federal attempts to put an end to
ottawa's obligation towards indigenous
people abigail beeman has our top story
tonight
every single day i had to be prepared
for the worst bouncing between 15 group
homes and foster homes since the age of
eight with a literal garbage bag for her
belongings cheyenne stonechild is now
lead representative plaintiff in a class
action suit against the federal
government just certified by the federal
court
there's so many kids that are lost
there's so many kids that can't be here
there's so many kids that
the expectations are so high
that
i'm okay to do this the case seeks to
compensate off-reserve indigenous
children in canada's welfare system
fewer than 10 percent of kids in canada
are indigenous according to the 2016
census but indigenous children and youth
make up more than half of the foster
system population children living off
reserve were not included in january's
40 billion dollar settlement when you
look at the reconciliation and you know
we should be trying to make sure that
our most vulnerable are taken care of
and there is substantive
equity for all our children again
regardless of where they live we'll deal
with it as we've dealt with several
other uh class action suits
what's important is that justice arrives
for
for people who
who went through those difficult periods
we're hoping that the federal government
you know does change its tune and
decides to treat off-reserve metis
non-status inuit kids the same as on
reserve kids because they're just as
indigenous for years stonechild fought
to find her family and has been an
advocate for other indigenous kids since
she says the certification feels like
validation the courts at the very least
is that there's no distinction between
on and off reserve of indigenous kids
the certification is just the beginning
of this case lawyers say it's too early
to know how much compensation they could
be asking for nor exactly how many
children would be covered but they know
they number in the many thousands
abigail beeman global news ottawa
in washington the committee
investigating the january 6 attack
focused today on donald trump's pressure
campaign to get state officials to
overturn his election loss the committee
heard trump's own words on tape as well
as the devastating impact they had on
election workers which trump and his
allies singled out jackson proskow has
more
recounting the terrifying threats they
faced state election officials testified
about the extent of donald trump's
pressure campaign to overturn an
election he'd lost from public rallies
to be raiding phone calls the real truth
is i won by 400 000 votes at least
so
so what are we going to do here folks i
only need 11 000 votes fellas i need 11
000 votes give me a break there were no
votes to find that was an accurate count
that had been certified trump's
well-known attempt to pressure officials
in georgia to find the votes he needed
was just part of it in arizona state
officials say trump and his team
repeatedly made wild accusations did
anyone provide you with evidence of
election fraud sufficient to affect the
outcome of the presidential election in
arizona
no one provided me ever such evidence
trump and his associates pushed a scheme
to select a fake slate of electors in an
attempt to block certification of joe
biden's electoral college victory on
january 6th and i said look
you are asking me to do something
that is counter to my oath
when i swore to the constitution to
uphold it even as legal challenges
failed in the courts trump and his team
pushed ahead knowing their plan likely
broke the law at the request of the
trump campaign the electors from these
battleground states signed documents
falsely asserting that they were the
quote duly elected electors from their
state the scheme went so far as to send
those fake electoral votes to washington
in hopes vice president mike pence would
consider them on the sixth pence refused
but trump didn't stop there the depth
and breadth of his campaign included
public attacks on two election workers
from georgia a mother and daughter
trump's team falsely alleged they stole
thousands of ballots she's a vote
scammer a professional vote scammer and
hustler
do you know how it feels to have
the president of the united states to
target you what's remarkable is that it
was all so brazen and as we know so much
of it is on tape what happened in
georgia may in fact carry the most
criminal liability for the former
president a grand jury is now
investigating and that's all entirely
separate from the questions about
trump's role in the attack of january
6th miku jackson proskow in washington
thanks
damning testimony today at a texas
senate hearing into last month's mass
shooting at an elementary school in
uvalde the state's top cop says there
were enough officers on scene to have
stopped the gunman just minutes after he
entered the building calling the police
response an abject failure
three minutes after the subjects entered
the west building
there was sufficient number of armed
officers wearing body armor
to isolate distract and neutralize the
subject
the only thing stopping a hallway of
dedicated officers from in room 111
and 112
was the on-scene commander
who decided to place the lives of
officers before the lives of children
19 children and two teachers were killed
as officers waited for over an hour for
reinforcements and a key to the
classroom mccraw testified the classroom
door was unlocked saying there is no
evidence officers ever tried to open it
delays in the police response have
become the focus of the federal state
and local investigation of the massacre
far to the west of ukraine an isolated
russian territory is fast becoming
another flashpoint while russia
continues its advance in ukraine's
eastern donbass region the kremlin has
warned lithuania an eu and nato member
there will be severe consequences if
more rail shipments are blocked to
kaliningrad as redmond shannon reports
the small region is not connected to
mainland russia and is already seeing
the consequences of new economic
sanctions
far from the battlefields of ukraine
peaceful kaliningrad could emerge as a
new focal point in the war the region
has changed hands over the centuries
most recently after the second world war
when the soviet union annexed it from
germany about half the size of vancouver
island kaliningrad is a russian exclave
on the baltic sea sandwiched between eu
members poland and lithuania it relies
on russian goods sent by rail through
belarus and lithuania since new eu
sanctions came into effect last friday
its governor says 50 percent of imports
are being blocked including coal and
construction materials
russia's security council secretary
visited on tuesday saying the
consequences will have a serious
negative impact on lithuania
and its people what exactly that means
for the nato member is as yet unclear
lithuania's prime minister says the
situation is the result of an eu
sanction and not a lithuanian blockade
the eu's ambassador to moscow was
summoned to the russian foreign ministry
on tuesday i appealed to the russian
side
to remain cool-headed
not to escalate
but de-escalation isn't a term vladimir
putin is using
the russian president told military
graduates that russia's newest
intercontinental nuclear missile will be
in operation by the end of the year as
he outlined plans to modernize the
country's armed forces
meanwhile the german and british
governments repeated their pledges to
further arm ukraine too we're determined
to provide more weapons impose more
sanctions and back ukraine in pushing
russia out of their territory the slow
and bloody fight for that territory
continues from both sides in the donbass
ukraine says russia has captured some
territory there in recent days but a
former senior u.s commander says the
arrival of more western weapons could
soon turn the tide in favor of ukraine
redmond shannon global news london
a russian journalist has sold his nobel
peace prize for a record-shattering
amount to help children displaced by the
war in ukraine
is there anybody else in this room or
the world
outfitting 100 million dollars on a
bitter 303
dmitry muratov's nobel medal ended up
selling for more than 133 million
dollars canadian to a still unidentified
bidder muratov who was awarded the prize
in october of 2021 put it up for auction
with all proceeds to go to unicef to
support ukrainian refugees
a treasured landmark of hong kong is now
lying at the bottom of the sea the
city's famed jumbo floating restaurant
capsized less than one week after it was
towed away from the city its parent
company says it encountered adverse
conditions in the south china sea the
three-story eatery welcomed more than 30
million visitors during its 44 years
including the queen and tom cruise it
was also featured in several films in
2020 the restaurant was forced to seize
operations because of the pandemic
train workers off the job and commuters
off track coming up the consequences of
britain's biggest rail strike in decades
plus the disturbing allegations at a
long-term care home in winnipeg
the biggest rail strike in more than 30
years is causing widespread disruption
all over the uk stations across the
country are closed and thousands of
scheduled trains have been canceled
after more than 40 thousand rail workers
walked off the job the union is planning
further walkouts for thursday and
saturday london's underground system is
also behind picket lines in a separate
pension dispute union leaders are
warning these strikes could be just the
beginning of a summer of labor strife
with airline employees teachers and
several other sectors also threatening
walkouts
prime minister justin trudeau is on his
way to rwanda for a summit with
commonwealth leaders the first such
meeting since 2018. from there trudeau
will travel to germany to meet with g7
leaders before attending the nato summit
in spain russia's war in ukraine
expected to dominate all three meetings
our chief political correspondent david
aiken is traveling with the prime
minister david
well need to prime minister justin
trudeau is going to once again call on
world leaders at all these summits to do
whatever they can to get russia to
withdraw from ukraine but world leaders
including the prime minister are also
seized with one of the big problems
caused by russia's illegal invasion of
ukraine global food insecurity mps from
all parties on the house of commons
agriculture committee understand the
urgency of the issue and are already
looking at ways canada might help i
think it's one of the most important
questions that we all collectively in
the world are facing ukraine and russia
are two of the world's largest food
producers war has not only disrupted
that production but russia is now
actively targeting ukraine's
agricultural capacity and has destroyed
some stores of grain at black sea ports
and given the fact that ukraine
feeds about 400 million people every
year
we know that
that the world is is in trouble
we're going to run out of food but
leaders at this trio of summits the
commonwealth of g7 and nato could
struggle to meet that challenge the
world is rather volatile and
economic conditions
may make things
difficult
because if you're looking at a recession
there won't be quite as much money to
hand around this is not just a 2022
problem the consequences of the war are
going to have reverberating impacts far
beyond 2022 and trudeau may face
difficult questions about what canada is
doing to help it is high time for for
canadian farming or canadian
ag to really think differently about
how to support the entire world when it
comes to food security because i don't
think canada's role has been all that
significant trudeau will touch down in
the rwandan capital of kigali wednesday
afternoon and he won't be back here in
ottawa until canada day nitu
thanks david
left to struggle ahead where's the money
ottawa promised to support canadians
mental health
police in manitoba are investigating
multiple allegations of abuse by at
least two workers at a personal care
home in winnipeg the winnipeg regional
health authority says the alleged abuse
took place at the oak view place
long-term care home and date back to
february details haven't been released
but officials say 15 residents were
involved two health care aides have been
put on paid leave as police conduct a
criminal investigation
the federal liberals are under fire over
missing mental health spending a marquee
promise in the party's 2021 election
platform four and a half billion dollars
was pledged over five years to help
provinces improve access to mental
health treatment but almost a year since
trudeau said it was a priority none of
the money has materialized jamie morocco
has more
five years ago leanne minicello's mental
health deteriorated to the point where
she worried she would lose custody of
her daughter i was feeling terrible i
mean i had suicidal thoughts and
everything the now 45 year old was
diagnosed with adhd and borderline
personality disorder without
provincially funded therapy she's not
sure she would be here i'm not the norm
i think about the children i think about
the parents and
people who aren't able to get this help
according to the canadian mental health
association the system is overwhelmed
and wait lists are long we knew going
into 2020 that the mental health system
wasn't equipped to deal with the strain
that was was on it prior to the pandemic
and now has only become much worse
mental health should be a priority
in august of last year justin trudeau
promised four and a half billion dollars
to provinces and territories for the new
mental health transfer but no money
including the initial 875 million
supposed to have been spent or budgeted
by now has materialized last week the
federal mental health and addictions
minister faced tough questions about the
promise
the platform promised that money to have
been spent right now so
that was a mistake there were concerns
that the five billion dollars in the
bilateral agreements wasn't transparent
and accountable for the money that was
being spent in march ottawa announced 45
million dollars to develop national
standards to ensure that accountability
in an email to global news bennett said
they will formalize what canadians can
expect in terms of timeliness and
quality of mental health services but
advocates say that's just a delay tactic
accommodations for people dianne young
lost her son to addiction and mental
illness in 2013. nine years later she
runs a not-for-profit treatment center
in his name
funding she says held her back for years
it's frustrating yes
it's sad more than frustrating that the
cost could continue to put canadians
lives at risk jamie morocco global news
toronto
back in the u.s covet 19 vaccinations
have finally started for many of its
youngest americans the rollout begins
after pfizer and modernist shots
covering those aged between six months
and five years got federal approval late
last week allowing roughly 18 million
kids to get protected from the virus
though relatively rare for the age group
about 480 children below five have died
of covet 19 in the u.s
honoring heritage and culture next the
celebrations across canada on this
national indigenous peoples day
national indigenous peoples day was
front and center on google canada's main
page today with a doodle celebrating an
influential first nations artist in
addition to a thunderbird and
anishinaabe florals the illustration
features the portrait of the late norval
morriso also known as copper thunderbird
called the picasso of the north he was
known for depicting traditional stories
spiritual themes and political messages
in his work he also founded the woodland
style that became popular among the
indigenous art community the doodle
itself was designed by first nations
couple blake anjokonib and danielle
morrison
from coast to coast on first nation
metis and inuit territory people
gathered for traditional ceremonies to
mark the occasion and while canada still
has a long way to go on the path towards
truth and reconciliation indigenous
communities proudly share their culture
on this day of remembrance and
celebration heather urex west reports
from treaty 6 territory in edmonton
to the ancestral and unseated lands of
the migma people in halifax
there were sounds of drumming and
dancing as members of many first nations
inuit and metis communities celebrated
the country's 26th national indigenous
peoples day
it's
wonderful to be able to show
you know all aspects of our cultures
here on turtle island
in toronto the day began with a sunrise
ceremony at nathan phillips square where
people gathered around a sacred fire to
make offerings we embrace our
relationships and you know that
beautiful road of reconciliation that
we're walking today we honor
all of the missing and murdered
indigenous women
we also honor all the children who've
been lost
in calgary the traditional territory of
the blackfoot satina iskia nakota and
metis the reconciliation walk to fort
calgary was filled with hope with
national indigenous people's day it's a
celebration of
the goodness too that has gone on
through the generations not just not
just the difficulties i've been feeling
really positively in recent years
i'm seeing more people like me on in the
media you know i'm feeling seen and
represented so
that's been really amazing
the discovery of unmarked graves near
the sites of former residential schools
across the country has prompted a
national reckoning over canada's
treatment of indigenous people and while
there is still a deep and collective
trauma among indigenous communities
there is also cause for great pride we
have a very strong cultural and a robust
community and we contribute
a lot indigenous people are
one and a half times more likely than
mainstream society to be business owners
and successful business owners
one of the many reasons to celebrate the
strength and resiliency of the people
that first called this land home
heather urex west global news calgary
and that is global national for this
tuesday night i'm nitu garcia whether
it's bc quebec or beyond we'll leave you
tonight with more scenes from across the
country today marking this 26 national
indigenous people's day thanks for
watching i'll see you here again
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you